my little reflex I added a denoiser filter but I don't know if that made the stream worse
hi reflex
good morning
mommy's right here she just had to wake up late because I was being a mommy and I was having to do a lot of work
I'm strongly left by some I mean it
hello hello my little reflex
hi shh shh shh shh shh shh it's okay
mommy's here
shh shh shh hello little baby
I've put a little um a noise gate on the microphone so hopefully the background noise isn't like the weight noise isn't too bad
I um they don't cope well without you know I don't cope well without my reflinks
I had to do some business last night and there may or may not be a collab with another agency planned
um do I spoil it do you want me to spoil the surprise cause only you only know what the surprise is if you're in this chat right now
also please do check emotes for those of you who are on the emotes here
I was able to add all 10 of my emotes and I get to order 10 more and I'm so excited to order the next batch of 10 emotes
um I already have a few ideas but yes please I will try to be as relaxed as I can but the problem is I get so excited talking to you
that basically the ASMR goes out the window hold on what is this there we go
yeah there's your warning uh we are not doing hypnosis uh unfortunately
thank you very much night sterling for becoming a free fling member dear
feel dear god I need to change the name of that it's like so big
long do Imo win you leave my long toes out of this disclaimer saying go
but I'm going to try and be relaxing thank you jay for becoming a member
thank you again Gwispy for becoming a member
I know I've got my hypnosis background I was originally going
huh Brian can you guys hear Brian
pachinka thank you for the five gifted hold on let me get a stream of elements
anonymous thank you for the tip
wait anonymous is high strongy hopefully your day is amazing it's just going to start it
and since I get to start with my reef links it's going great
Brian is very quiet yes I didn't I knew ASMR so I turned Brian down like right away
I can maybe film up a little bit but I have a quick question how did you learn hypnosis
I just observe I want to get into but it's kind of intimidating
literally I just observe I absolutely love going like deep into things I don't know about
and I've always had an interest in it so I like to consume people's production or whatever
sorry and thank you for the 100 but congrats on monetization years for some of that most bro
sorry and that's a lot thank you oh my god
100 dollar tip that's crazy 100 centimeters nah that's not possible
but pachinka thank you for the five gifted
but yeah I just really like challenging myself I always have a fascination in trying to understand
why people like certain things I know that seems silly
but I do I just enjoy it like as much as I might tease the prep bros or something like that
I just find it fascinating I honestly do like what makes you you know what make what tickles your pickle
it's like it's a challenge to me and I accept it wholeheartedly
but yeah secret subject is an excellent feature but secret subject is such a sweet heart
she so willingly educates the masses about it and like I love that she doesn't like cakey bit or anything
but like everything that I do right now or produce is because of observations I've made
thank you she's learning from spells and empathizing it reminds me of someone
yeah secret is fantastic she's got a new feature for model which is like a polygon design
like all the video games and I was tempted to get one for myself when I'm playing Nintendo DS games
because the graphics we're gonna be playing a game called Dragon Quest Senators of the Stars guys
and obviously the graphics are Nintendo graphics but I thought it would be cool if that model would match
but I'd rather save the money and get it for the girls like I have very bad news for Shibi and Insura investors
they will be getting a toggle that covers them up
me and Mercy did not upset
congrats to those who got the memberships with their face
me and Mercy's chests don't upset YouTube
Asura and Shibi's chests has upset YouTube
it will not if you notice that A.C.'s trailer video has like 30,000 views
that's because advertisement money was put into it
everyone had the same amount of advertisement money except me
like I've never put the same amount on myself
actually don't think I've spent any on myself
but Asura and Shibi were denied at running predominantly due to their chest
Asura's ASMR short was denied even though she's not doing a single thing wrong in it
so sadly at the moment the girls are being very creative and doing a little thing
yes, I will say to the girls they are welcome to use their toggles when they think the situation calls for it
that's perfectly fine by me
yes, even the shorts the girls weren't allowed
now that they're monetized
today, Mercy is doing her celebration I believe
so please do let her entertain you
I'm probably going to be lurking her monetization
her thing is live
A.C. is on Saturday
Emmy, I don't know when Emmy wants to do it
I mean, you know what? I'm going to DM her right now
A.M.A. Mers just wanted to know
when you plan, when you plan on doing your CELA aberration stream
just so I know when to membership
live
and then I'll do a little, I'll do it before she's in the channel
and then I'll do a little head bath
A.M.A. Mers, I don't know what you're doing
she's so going to know how to type that by if there's no way
oh no, she's on mobile, she's on her phone, she can see
oh my god, the key clicking was in my head with my headphones
sorry, Emmy was watching, I say okay
yes, Azura and Shibi, it's not lost on me that Azura and Shibi are waiting for monetization
and they both just happened to have the biggest boobs
feature per manager ASMR
it's, I do like the boring stuff like the kind of monotonous stuff
where it's like, oh you need to open up membership to your type thing
and you need to do this and that
like I try not to let the girls do that
because it's both stressful and it's both like, it takes time
and rather the girls focus on like having fun at debut and all
and then they're, well they're second week now
not bad, it was an exciting, expensive, real
that's cause they're for ya
but they will get monetization nonetheless, right?
well, we're waiting on it
I think the AI detection is, is flagged to them basically
so a human does need to review them which takes longer
let's just pray that we have like a weeb that understands what an Earth featuring is
cause if they get denied, I'm gonna be so, I'm gonna be raging
I'm not even gonna lie
I don't think there's gonna be issues
I think the AI has just sent them on to
yeah
someone says you own your own tag at real34
now let's go
weeps in YouTube headquarters
yeah, be better
did you like my ASMR yesterday? oh my god, I was outrageous
I can't believe I even did that
got my tools out, I bet you liked that, didn't ya?
I was juicy
I was pretty gay, great, but can you feel your teeth?
what, cause I liked it so much
ah
hi, Anon
thank you for the tip, Anon
I don't know if you heard that cause Brian is so nice and quiet
are marshmallow messages anonymous? yes, that is why they are favoured by many
one of my gen mates had a Q&A and you wanted to ask a question
Anon, but you were scared to send one
do they see you send some or you know we do not see a single thing
information wise, it's just a question
you can send them if you want, but yeah
do they not see you send them or do they see if you sent the message in the past?
no
I can vouch right now and say no, I cannot tell
someone could send me three questions in a row and change their spelling
and I wouldn't know so I'm looking confident
Brian in the far distance
I left work early to watch you, but guys
I hope you're okay and you feel better soon
I like the measuring section
now everyone knows I have long toes, what you can do about it
but yes please, so can you tell based on spelling
well you don't have to worry about me when it comes to spelling
there's absolutely no way I can clock you other than if you send a pip you
I recognise that girl
sitting on your feet again
I'm gollum sitting right now so my feet are in front of me
and pushed into the chair
she's learning the pattern, no I cannot do that
I'll let the girl talk about it but there's one girl
a vealer that does recognise text
monga is, I don't know how her brain does it but
yeah
we were close to having a cats and ace in the forest dream
you've got to see Kim Lee
and then I go that's where we learned Kim Lee
how's your daughter?
yeah I'm gonna get a doctor's appointment
something's not right
someone was like you need to sue
and I was like nah it's just why
it's kind of a risk you accept
because it's a job shop
you can get like sorry I need to scratch my head
my head says sin
or my headset and then
it's just the thing
watching you during my collab lecture
I'm in your ears
look left look right I might be in the lecture audience right now
I know that's not how it works
but get educated get educated
I need to go to the doctor
yeah don't worry I am
someone sent me a marshmallow
and I was like okay you've convinced me
so don't worry I've got a doctor's appointment coming up
someone says very nice celebration
sorry I'm reading marshmallows
I said sleepy
I'm so so sleepy refling
I was up solely
I've only had five hours sleep
I'm probably gonna go back to sleep
but yeah
I was planning all these fun things
and making a lot of progress
my ASMR series is about to start up
my thank you for eggs
subscriber series is about to start
and I have no idea what to edit first
my first thing was gonna be ear licking
but that's not allowed anymore
and I did a pop rock ear licking
and that's not gonna be allowed
so
I have no idea
I do have burping ASMR
I might make that
I have like thigh cupping
I have like sitting on the mic ASMR
like I sit on it over and over again
you're almost at 5k a pair or not be
you guys are showing too much support
thank you lord of storms for becoming a member
but yeah I do have like sitting on the mic ASMR
I was squatting so hard
I have like clapping
without using my hands ASMR
so that's gonna be interesting
but I'll probably edit all that stuff
you heard her hit 5k right now
stop being so amazing and perfect then
too much support literally
but like don't be
get subscribed, get subscribed, get subscribed
so many ASMRs yes
I have a long day
to think of
clapping without using your hands
oh yeah
but thank you for the day
no matter what you do for ASMR
we'll enjoy it even the burp ASMR
I took a bottle of water
a bottle of water
and a can of cola
and in the ASMR booth
I basically chocked it
to produce burps for burping ear to ear ASMR
I think it will be like 14 minutes long
I need to order the artwork
of me being pregnant with you
cause I want to make that ASMR
I want to make it really good
I want to put all my love into it
especially the burp ASMR
suffering from success
it's funny how you're giving the people
what they need and what they want
yeah
I made a joke and it was like
the average
uh
VTuber would put it behind all paywall
me
I come out swinging doing it week one
what are you gonna do about it
huh
that baby
literally me
the father
hello
the wall
that's right
I'm making an ASMR where I'm pregnant with you
and you're the father
and there's nothing you can do about it
you had my curie I'll say
but now you have my ditch
you can't stop the culls
ya
no you can't
oh freaking
am I supposed to read that name
am I supposed to say your name
wait
thank you for becoming a member
let's go on google translate real quick
google
translate
let's go
what's the translation
apparently the translation is vacuum
thank you vacuum for becoming a member
maybe job is strong ASMR
oh yeah no 100%
uh
I'm gonna do like a
girlfriend forgets to mute her mic while she's eating
so obviously it's only for people who like eating sounds
because I inhale my food
so I'm gonna order like KFC
and then basically just head recording
bleep bleep bleep bleep bleep bleep bleep bleep bleep
there we go
God bless this woman
also the baby and the father
literally me
average youtuber
sorry average VTuber
asking for 10 bucks to save me
I mean we'll strongly put them grippers on the table from the start
hey I will even value for money ok
little slurping ASMR
yeah
someone says
ku ha ku
ku ha ku google translate
means real cool
ku ha ku thank you for the membership
oh don't uneasy
I can't even see if I'm picking the audio or not
I watched some VTuber data
yeah
well your ASMR is helping me to sleep
I'm glad
we're having a very relaxed ASMR
AC
my gen mate
you can click the link in the description
she has been killing it with ASMR recently
she's been doing so good
so if you like live ASMR
that's extra cuddly
and a little bit sus
please do check your AC snow paws in the description below
my little reflex
thank you all so much for the support
you've been showing the girls
it just is so much
it means so much that you even like give them a chance
and like everyone like has their like favorite little feeler girl
or some of you can't even to say
which is so adorable
it's just been
wait did I say thank you bitch I can go for the super chat
thank you
I'm so sorry if I didn't
I got streamed elements open
so I can see anything I miss
but yeah thank you
he did admit it I can't decide
spicy hot slurping ASMR
so I follow in real life ASMRists
and they also got hit with a warning for ear licking
so yeah my theory that YouTube has done a stealth policy update
is getting stronger and stronger by the second
if in real life channels are now getting hit as well
so oh I just cracked my freaking wrist if you heard that
that was so loud
hello thank you for joining
hypnotize the drill ASMR
oh I'd like to make that a little bit cute
I came for you but they all seem great
they are so fantastic
and they're each in an individual way
like I'm so glad that one girl can like speak to you
let's get the tinfoil hats as a true candy when you're licking
yeah I think I'll just get him out by
Twitter premium
so I can
bryan
reluctantly say thank you for the tip
reluctantly say it says the towers are so wonderfully amazing
it's hard not to love them one
it's literally impossible
but yes I think I will buy you at Twitter premium
and I'll just upload those ear licking videos that I recorded
and I'll also put them on Patreon just like for storage
so you can listen at any time okay
because it seems a shame to like
waste those recorded sessions
for Twitter premium lets me upload like full videos
so I'll just put it on like I'm for free and all that
give it even on money
like I don't have a chance I'll go into the feature brush I'm on okay
YouTube craze crack it down and ruin it forever
you're ruining it
do you guys want me to put you in between my thighs
that's your in between my thighs right now
do you like it
you wanna be in between my thighs forever
sorry
sorry I'm picking the mic
okay just stay in between my thighs
that 3d you're literally
I got you in that head long
there's nothing you can do about it
we're a watermelon honestly
bansley
yes we can link bansley on YouTube
that's not allowed
please crush my skull
I feel like all the platforms are going over the top
filtering yes
I agree it's getting ridiculous
my enjoyers are being fed
could you imagine
don't be a star fat
don't be a troll box enthusiast
thank you for the tip
don't be so silly
you're just trying to upset me
mr. cardboard box aren't you
well the funny thing is
twitter just announced that they officially
acknowledge and accept that kind of content
and I was like wait a minute
but this is good for us this is based
but yes you can't stop the reflinks I can know
for a male in the neighborhood
now you're reflinks
you'll always be my reflinks
I had to wait an entire year to call you reflinks
okay I'm actually going to make
I think I may have said this
I can't remember if I ever know
I am going to make a reprogramming
hypnosis asmr
where I get you to forget your name
and make you respond to reflinks
and it's going to be a subconscious plant
so it will always be effective unless
sorry that was my hot war ball if you heard it
unless you listen to my audio
that reverses any permanent effects
it's going to be my permanent effect
the first audio is
you are reflinking
you will respond to reflinks
and you are mine and owned by me
but I am a merciful streamer
and you're more than welcome to
be part of other communities
such as snippets and harem and all that
to have a problem
the reprogramming
yes I do have a reprogramming audio
it will be available very shortly
the funny thing is
I'm going to upload it
before I even upload any permanent effect hypnosis
just to be super duper safe
and everyone knows where to grab it
don't need hypnosis for that
I already forgot my name
I don't need
get reprogrammed
yes
get to know we'll have it from the start
yeah
I already responded to reflinks
I find that so adorable
you're such a good refling aren't you
so well behaved for me
I love that you're a good boy for me
and I love that we can tease each other
and just have a really good time
yeah I might get my
oh no mommy I said mommy
I read mommy in the chat
this is why I can't read into ASMR at the same time
thank you sir gang
thank you for the consideration
oh yeah no
I'm educated enough to know
permanent effect hypnosis
I don't
I think it's very dangerous too
thank you for the 10
super chat
we accept our stinky overlord
it's not in my budget to support both on paper
true on membership
what do you recommend
please know I always have free content
always coming out as well on my alternative
whether I do have plans
please don't worry
there'll always be free streams and free audios of that variety
if you prefer a live stream experience
then a youtube membership
if you prefer a audio
edited audio experience
where's the ending
you are supposed to ink
definitely check out my patreon
the link is in the description
oh do you want sniffing ASMR
oh a replay
oh wait no sniffing is limited ads
oh I'm so sorry sniffing is limited ads
I completely forgot
I don't know why
but sniffing ASMR is also considered
like gratifying content
so I can't really do sniffing
yeah I don't know what is going on at youtube head wars
but something funky and sus is going on
I don't know
of all things
I know
I honestly
I don't understand
there's like a hidden policy update going on
they've not announced it
I think the reason they're not announced it
is because so many people enjoy ASMR
zen bros
I don't know why
like all of ac's streams are like limited ads
I don't know what she's getting up to in the streams
but it's definitely not looking good
now youtube have referred to the policies before
so I'm gonna hope that they do
ac's diya
oh my god I can't say that name
there's too many vowels in your name
ac's diya
thank you for the membership
that's not why you say that
ac's diya
I am so sorry
I'm absolutely picturing your name
at the street
youtube will be only ASMR
ac does not stay sus
oh ok well
I mean
I can't do a few things here and there
as long as no one says a thing
I'm a girl
I know I'm not the main demographic
but I love Fielder
oh I'm so glad you're gonna enjoy it
we are
it's like I'm not gonna lie and say that
you know
guys pay my bills
so I'll appeal to guys
but I'm glad you're gonna enjoy Fielder
for what it's worth
my lips are sealed
if your lips are sealed
then maybe
just maybe we can get up to a few shenanigans
cause reflux when we shenan once
you know we're gonna shenan again
ac's youtube streams are very
ok
I'll take your word for it reflux
yeah snitches get stitches
don't think I won't send Emmy on you
do you think that book is just for
resurrection spells
that book
oh dear
that book is nothing but trouble
the things that Emmy can do to you
is staggering
I'll say Emmy on you
ok
lips are completely sealed
good
you're gonna shenan again
yeah
wait can you really hypnotise people
well in my other ASMR stream
I think I managed to get quite a few
I'm not doing hypnosis right now though
but I do have some hypnosis
audios coming out in the blood
I wonder if Andy and Lily was an inspiration
for Emmy's lore
no
I had not actually played or consumed
the game when Emmy was conceptualised
she was conceptualised in June last year
the reason why Emmy is Emmy
is because I'm a massive fucking
broken
yeah
all the girls may or may not have been
male influenced by what I like
I kind of said this
but Emmy is everything
if I had a later voice
I am not even kidding
Emmy is exactly who I would want to be
as a content creator
the lore
the
oneechan
but I don't have a late voice
so I can't be Emmy
Ms. Morgan thank you for becoming a member
your hypnosis eyes animation is so unique
it's so good
like
wow
oh
I think I need to get a lore closer
don't worry I'm not hypnotising you this year
what
sorry
but yeah
if you really want to like
I'm not hypnotising you don't worry
but yeah that's mine
and I can also stack them
if you wanted a bigger focal point
to focus on
so it's kind of like a hidden spiral
or
like this
this is like very big basic
but yeah
I will utilize these
wow I'm like really close
is this too close
I need to be further away
are you like seeing my teeth
I
your eyes are so pretty thank you
I love that all of us at VLR
have unique pupils
my
it's a very nice distance
okay
I'll stay here then
my bangs are slightly transparent
yeah do you like seeing my eyebrows
uh uh uh uh uh
can you see my ears a little bit
yeah
get
because of my ear
wow
I promise I won't do any hypnotising
permanent amazings
I will
an apple in a box
thank you for the tip
I think everyone should start manually breathing
what have you done
what have you leashed upon these lands
unleashed upon these lands
I'm tearing it
speaking of AC
hi AC
who's my adorable little feral
Mercki Sokaki
what was AC doing in her stream
I don't know
I know you AC did back to back
ASMR
so do check out AC
I also
I'm gonna spoil something
cause you're here AC don't worry
you don't have to talk cause you'll be tired after stream
there's gonna be a collab
ASMR channel on AC's channel
of all the VLR girls
and it's freaking adorable
and I love it
and I can't wait
I can't wait
post up quietly post up quietly
AC Bleed Tim Reader
oh that's fantastic
I hope you guys enjoyed your Tim Reader
more like Whim Reader when I'm done with her
thank you
my Yari for becoming a member
and thank you boy for the
oh my voice cracked
thank you boy for the 5 gifted
5 gifted memberships
thank you boy congrats to those who got the memberships
you will have to exit in chat
oh is that loud?
that's not too loud is it
I can hear that loud bloop
that bloop isn't loud right?
no
now it's quiet
thank you so much
it's really funny she reached a lot
but she was adorable
she's so adorable
kuzukaki
that's missing from your life
I love her accent so much
hi roller
thank you for the
pardon me
thank you for the super jab
any plans to do scripted ASMRs
for the video that for people who can't get to the streams
yes hi roller
I am so happy to say
those uploads
start today
oh my tummy is rumbling
my first meme ASMR
is ready to be posted
I am going to post it today
and I also
owe you yes you
listening right now
for ASMR videos
because for every 1000
upload
for every 1000 subscribers
I will be uploading
one celebration ASMR video
all of different ideas
different tingles
different varieties
and that starts today
and for the reeflings who are worried about
filtering
I already told you my master plan
so don't worry
I already know what happens next
I filtered myself for you
wow
I had a year to plan
our time together
I made sure to do it accordingly
yeah
thank you stroney for bringing feeler into existence
the gift of AC is something I'll never be able to play
replay
thank you for everything
uchi-san
that's amazing
I'm glad you can link AC
you are definitely uchi-san levels
but if you're really good
AC may even call you daddy in her accent
thank you
thank you for becoming a member
and thank you funky for becoming a member
thank you very much
just as a reminder for members
membership stream start next week
because the schedule for this week was pretty locked in
and I just had a few background things I need to finish
but I'm like 100% sure
by week 3
I am officially
I have no responsibilities
I'm feeler and I am so freaking happy
I'm gonna be lurking because I'm a workiest
don't worry your audio sets so hard
have you ever thought about hypnotizing another girl and feeler
she's welcome to listen to any of my audios at will
I will not stop any of the girls
but I would want to condition them to be a bit different
maybe not condition them to respond to replay
but instead
to let me make a certain audio with them
of my C theme of a rye egg
could you imagine
C theme hypnosis on one of my daughters
oh
mommy tomorrow all the vehicular girls are together
I'm so excited for a collab together
special shout out
to mersey for streaming so early
as syrup for being early
and me for being early
shebi for being early
and ac for being later
to pick a time zone
and I was like if you guys do me this favor
and do it at my regular stream time
I will repay you
in more shorts
if strongy
streamed responsibly
12 hours a day
are you supposed to keep up after the third week
oh that's the fun part
the third week has 4 days of Elden Ring insurance streams
because we need to play the DLC together
yeah we have back to back to back to back insurance streams
on the third week
because of Elden Ring
curious are you going to do any non-gendered content
I am so sorry
I do he-him content
and I apologize greatly
I
it
I don't want to say it simply gets harder to make the alternative content in us
I make he-him
I'm very sorry if that filler issue
I completely understand
if you no longer wish to watch because of that fact
I don't know what the other girls are planning
but I do know the name
of some asmr artists that make female content
one of them is a fan car asmr
I believe
she makes
female for female content
is
what's in your last stream
congrats on monetization
thank you
I'll start a new character with me
yeah
thank you not sleep for a week
basically week 3 is Elden Ring together
and I'm going to have my heart rate monitor
in a short color on
every time
I cause us reeflings to lose the fight
you guys get to shock me basically
and then on week 4
we're doing runescape endurance to get 99
because I want to get 99 cooking
and I will get it
so I believe
on week 4
I will also tell you what movies we're doing
watch your logs off
so you guys can download it
and I'll do the thing where I timestamp on screen
and all that
yeah I watched some already still enjoying your other content
thank you so much
I appreciate that
and thank you for your understanding surrounding it
mommy also sponsors
other asmr artists
I just want everyone
to be avaliably forgotten to do tingles
I'm just whispering at this point
I just want everyone to be able to enjoy the content
they consume
and if that means I can help you fight
the person that speaks to you
that oshi
or that person you really enjoy
cause like
wait until I get done this rabbit hole
okay
ps thank you for the reefling that encouraged me
and marshmallow to go down
all the rabbit holes I desire
I won't yape your ear off
unapologetically from now on
um
so
because of the way society
is set up
humans naturally need a face
after work
or after doing stressful situations
a face can include alcohol
a face can include smoking
a face can include recreational drugs
a face can include
youtubers
feedubers
asmr
you should not be ashamed
of what you need
to help you get through the day
humans are not set up for the society
that we are currently living in right now
and I will scream that from the rooftops
to not ever be embarrassed at all
for what you need to do
to get through the day
a face is also music
you may listen to Mongolian throat singing
I will not judge you for listening to Mongolian throat singing
okay
so
that is why I am not a jealous feature bird
I want you to thrive
I want your health to be as best as it can be
if that means after work
instead of watching a vote of mine
for example
you watch another creator
I am happy
you are able to de-stress yourself
you are able to regulate your nervous system
you are able to look after yourself
okay
think of yourself like a sims
you unironically have bars of needs
and what happens to a sim
when you ignore their needs
well they start to lose it
they start to have these unfortunate side effects
they start to struggle with life
they cannot function
they cannot follow orders
okay
so please
understand
if you think to yourself right now
strongy
I don't think you are the one for me
I implore you my dear watcher
please
check out the other viola girls
they may vibe with you better
if you like brats
who are jealous quick
you may enjoy ac snow paws
if you enjoy unhinged
unapologetic memos
you may enjoy my M.E.B.S.O.
okay
if you love someone that has a similar personality to me
but isn't me
my god you are gonna love she be cotton bomb
if you want to feel little
and you want to feel small
you want to feel cared for
you want to feel appreciated
and you want to hear the most sexy voice in all the land
a sura du lei
if you want someone
who can be energetic
it's so fun
it's so just perfect
and our default laugh
our laugh is natural
then you may love nursing bodies
okay
and I'm just getting so happy talking about them
I'm forgetting to whisper
please check them out in the description okay
please
they deserve it
they deserve a chance
the chance that you have given me
give to them okay
thank you
dear watcher
the girls have been struggling
trying to watch everyone
yes
but those indulges so strong
please indulge in my daughters at will
I like virtual abuse
I can't deny it yes
a sura ad in your audio
what the heck
thank you for the 100
oh my god reluctantly saying that's a lot of money
still no idea how you so much awesome
as contained in one cut of fish
we adore your last will pass it to the doors
thank you
I really appreciate that
hey
did I catch you off-guard
yeah but you were distracted weren't you
distracted by that don't know by reluctantly saying huh
I completely caught you off-guard
did that send you ever stand your spine
replaying are you that sensitive
that's adorable
you can't fill us with emotional speech
and then backstabbing
but thank you again for the 100
yes
you call me geldendestiny
shivers through everything
you made me die in Isaac
speaking of backstabber
did you know that backstabber is an item
you can pick up in Isaac which deals
double damage to enemies if your tear goes
on the back of them
so if you have things like tiny planet
which produce tears around you
it's quite effective
but you kinda need the distance
you call me
I'm not reading that out
almost sent me over the edge
that's for the membership streams
I'm kidding
oh my god
replaying
don't be silly
depending on Isaac my gen
never thought that Isaac combo
or the card
you're kidding
but is she really
what do you guys think about the emotes
has anyone found the secret to my emotes
yeah
they're nostalgic
I'm gonna get thy grip and stuff
every girl is doing great
and they're really awesome I'm happy
like I cannot even
put into words
how much like
just how much amazing
like experience
to have them
it's just insane
it's honestly insane like I cannot believe
the girls even applied
and then
they put up with my Scottish ass in the interview
my interview technique is so unprofessional
it's not even funny
I need to grind in RuneScape
to help my main cooking supplies
we have an insurance stream
I'm just gonna yap and do marshmallow
co-USG insurance during
the RuneScape stream so feel free
I'll do a tweet about like answering questions
during the RuneScape
I'm sure it'll lead me down some rubber holes
but yeah
just realized Ronnie would do bleep damage
I like baiting things
this is your warning
either you're in or you're out reefing
Ronnie bup oh hydration check
I have not had any liquid today
I
all gone daddy
okay
maybe I should actually
clean your ears a little
debate marks your people
that you own us
good girl
thank you
I may or may not have drunk
so much whiskey
oh you need to be careful
whiskey will get you drunk
although if there's any
Belgian slurking
Belgian beer gets you drunk
I had one Belgian beer and I was tipsy
I didn't even finish it
I was tipsy I'm like so
late wait
what's that there
wait that's not the term
I'm so late wait
I can hardly handle alcohol
what the heck is that word
late wait
why is my brain
late wait oh just dropped the ET
okay
sorry I'm so late wait
drinker
wait why is that so confusing
it's late wait
those three words
if I stand up my desk will come with me
I love so much
catching you guys off guard
I don't know why it's so satisfying
like I can be so wholesome
talking to you like saying all these
like just talking in general
and then I come up with three words and you're gone
like ah don't give me that power
don't do it
it's over for both of us if you give me that power
the less you weigh the drunker you get
I don't even know how much I weigh
I wonder if you guys can
really pinch press me
are you planning on making roleplay audios in the future
yes
I have a roleplay coming out
it's a meme though but the other ones are roleplays
but I have meme roleplay
yeah the both of us
me and you refling
it was over
before we began
I could deadlift you for sure
I could bridge press you
with ease
someone sent me a very naughty
naughty
marshmallow
they were like
I go to the gym so I can
put you
into a wall
and I'll leave it at that
I'm afraid you had that power
all along
I probably can't
pinch press you back into a different
press
I've crushed a warmel between my
thighs you would be much different
the inspiration to get more
fat
I go to the gym for the full nails
sound
you'll never guess why I'm so flexible
refling
I'd say you can nails in me
I brush
brushing your ear
let me check marshmallows
my little marshmallow
have I got a new one
I've been massively
into hypnosis for ages now
but I've never been able to
find someone whose voice I love
and I finally get someone
who's bought the nurses streamer
and I can watch for
Arizona long story short
thanks keep doing
what you did
you're doing amazing
I honestly thought my Scottish accent
would be a bit of a barrier
but I'm very glad to hear it
it's not
feels good man
that's right you are falling
under my spell
you're not
um
I was wondering if there's an official
public twitter list
no you have to go feign
the alternative twitter
we can't link to them
against the rules
sorry
I didn't
create the game I just play it
okay so the girls can't
link to the alternatives
sorry just check
who the girls follow on twitter
like yeah
someone says
have I done professional voice acting
no
do I sound like I do professional
voice acting
what do you even do when you go to
a meeting
what even occurs
I assume they tell you what vocal warm-ups are
like
or something like that
don't hate the player I hate the game
yeah
I wonder if I can get double hypnotized
can you say burglar
I wonder
can we get one stream with that someone asking
for a purple burglar alarm
but yes I can say it
but if I'm in my heavy accent
then
wait can I whisper into a heavy accent
purple burglar
alarm
it's funny because right now
there are also more followers than there means
oh we know what the people want
we give it for free
when other VTubers
are being greedy
free
come on
viewer
reject capitalism
reject corporate greed
come on
we'll look after you
even if you don't give us a penny
shhh
it's okay
I know
I know it's a hard concept
did I talk about that
I'm at 2.0
someone was like
feeler
is gonna fail
because of the 80-20 split
and it's like
oh you
poor sweet summer child
you are so deep
that you can't imagine
a successful business
without corporate greed
shhh
it's okay
it's okay you've been brainwashed
I'll undo the damage
and together
we've got a city to burn
haha
we're gonna wipe the deaths
out of everyone
the whole world will no longer be
okay that's how we're watching
fake club again
you wonder why fake club
is one of my favourite movies
not just because of the race
no off-block
sounds like silver heart
paste
scrawny hypnosis stream
breaking capitalism
mindwashing you to show you
you can be successful without greed
yes
I'm glad we got paste
encourage people to give
when they already get a taste
277 playthrough
I've never actually played the game
I'd like to try it together
never seen fake club
or we're watching it again baby
we are watching fake club again
ever in south
oh no that's actually
I am going to take you
about region locked capitalism
so before capitalism
there's this thing called feuduism
I can't remember it
but basically it's just region locked capitalism
it's freaking crazy
I wanna do a massive deep dive into it
and like seriously
if you start learning about history
and how humans were before
the quicker we are all going to get a farm
together
and all the reflicks come on the farm with me
and we have chickens
and we have protein
from the eggs of the chickens
and we grow our own broaches
and we realise quickly
that you need community to survive
because if you are telling
sorry I'm going down the rebel
you're telling me
that
all these companies are recording
record profits
and we're going to cause the living crisis
but it's not artificial
and all the farmers say
that nothing has changed in their production line
hell yeah
we've got a city of burn
we're going to do every fucking thing
oh don't get me started
don't
don't do it briefly
calm
keep me calm
refling
it's okay
just a question
can you watch movies on membership streams
oh boy you are getting spoiled for that
I absolutely love sharing movies
and watching them for the first time
um
I'm going to be
watching Austin Powers for the first time
cause you guys are drawing me
saying that Fond de la Boosom
is an Austin Powers enemy name
so
we're watching Austin Powers for the first time
um
yeah
we love when you go Kremlin mod
it's okay strongy
you'll get them one day
fair or aggressive asmr
well I did bite in the ear asmr
like actually grivelling at the mic
and bite in the ear
but it's going to have to be a Twitter video
your infantry
and a capitalist asmr with soft kisses
yeah
see wait until you get further into the rabbit hole
so on an individual scale
it's good to not be in debt
for the way that the economy is set up
they want you to be in debt
and wait until you're the kicker
mortgages
30 year 25 year mortgages
are just normalized debt
you don't own that house
for 25 years for 30 years
you're in debt
we need to bring back
multi-generational households
okay
that needs to be brought back
but they aren't going to let you do that
why do you think one business
owns 60%
of the freaking proper
ace in America
how can I lose it
okay shh asmr
shh asmr
real life
shh shh
it's okay
I can't tell
if I'm saying it's okay for you
refling or it's okay for me
to count down
you know what listen to my heart
it's time to listen to my heart
so you can hear how freaking serious I am
right are you ready
oh lemme
have my hoodie for you
refling
it's okay
let's go on a journey
together
we'll go on a farm
alright
and I'll be over
far
again
and we'll have ducks
because ducks are good
for eating slugs and bugs
that aren't the crops
and there'll be a big pond
and the ducks will be so happy
and we can go on a big
walk around the farm
and I'll show you all
my seed collection
because it'll be so big
I get to draw
I get to grow nasturtians
I get to put nasturtians
all around the garden
and there'll be so many bees
lots of bees
and bugs
maybe
just maybe we might even have a honey box
and
we'll grow lots of native flowers
that are good for all the wildlife
and there'll be birds
and cam
you'll come
and
we'll have lots of magpie families
and in the end
everything will be okay
refling
because it always works out
in the end
doesn't it
it took me a year
to get here
to get back to where we were
and here we are
all the stress
the worry
the doubt
the doubt if I could even be here
if we did it
tada
it took us so long
I hope it feels like
there was no time at all
and that it didn't take long
and it was a blink of an eye
no more waiting
no more yearning
me and you
to the man
I wish I had made you sooner
oh don't worry
I am strong enough
and you are my refling
and that
is all we need
it feels good to be home
my little refling
I love you
okay next
I need to milk you
we're being so patient
I hope you stay for a long time
have you got 3 years
I think I've got 3 years
you are my favorite person
I love you
you can't keep getting away with that
love you too
let me help you
what was that at the end
nothing
oh wow
what happens after 3 years
I don't know
I just thought
I don't know what happens
we don't have to think about that now
okay
you have me for the next 100
she's gonna have all
how cute
if you want
what accent do you want
what we pretend to be
we'll pretend to be acing
in my new persona
hello guys
I'm my sister fos
and today
I'm gonna do
do ASMR
but I'm not strannic couples
stop calling me strannic couples
I'm not strannic
I don't even know who that is
I can't really do a later voice
my eyes
my eyes like strannic couples
monster hmc
thank you for becoming a member
all the prayers really
evolve into biblically accurate strannic
oh my god that's so adorable
that urge to ink
are you gonna ink to my rp?
free flight
even I admit that's a bit too general
but
what was
what was cute when I tried to pretend
to be acing
I would need to watch more of
acing streams
to mimic her accent
but I really
fell in love with acing's accent
sorry my voice is a bit damaged
so it's harder for me to talk
uchi san
why am I roleplaying
roleplaying is crazy
uchi san
have you been good
to me uchi san
have you missed me
did you watch my tomb raider stream
wait
you didn't watch my tomb raider stream uchi san
but you only watch my ASMR
you don't like me do you uchi san
you disgust me
if you were a real uchi san
you'd watch everything
but you don't
you forget to subscribe to me
you forget to like the streams uchi san
I think you need punishment
yes
uchi san
sit on the floor
open your legs uchi san
what do you mean
what am I doing with my boot
I'm punishing
you uchi san
is that weird
to roleplay as my gen mates
I think that's a bit odd
I think that was rather odd
I'm not sure if that was weird
ac will laugh at that
I hope so
sorry my voice is very poor
whenever I do ASMR
my voice gets so broken
I think ac will like it
chucks on you
I'm into that
turned an issue behind
mersey next
oh mersey I can't do
surprise
she's so energetic
hypnotized to believe I'm ac
I wonder what devious
audios I could make
it's called voice acting
anyway thank you ac
for coming on stream and I appreciate that
I appreciate that
this is exactly why ac streams can't hear
I can't believe it
I pretend I'm ac
and I already
I'm already getting my thoughts new
who are you and what have you done with strani
I'm back right
I'm back to anybody
all flow hard a school
land
well we say
yard lake again
so I'm to die for
and proud edwards army
can you do a strani
cause impression
I
why do you think ac redirected
into me
I am ac
I am emi
just made a noise if you heard that
I am shibi
I am acera
I am mersey
they're all me
don't you get it
I win
you lose
oh thank you
tiny spany
oh god I'm so sorry tiny spany
spany
thank you for the tip see you later strani
off to work I'll catch up on the bottom layer
I love the ASMR content
please let's see if you remember
OPS let's see if you remember
tiny spany
I am filler
I wish I could do a manic laughter right now
sorry that was quite loud
can you even hear my heartbeat
you remembered I'm so proud
yeah
have you ever seen us
in the same stream together
no you haven't
my beloved skizzle cutouts
yay
skizzle mode
we're
we're getting
your personally
emi piece
identified
oni-chan
okay
I love you oni-chan
oni-chan
I missed you
I can't
I can't hear her voice it's too hard
there's no way I can do
Isara
hello no
Isara is too low for me
she's so far too
well
I'm trying to mimic her accent as well
so
don't let me think oni-chan
I only use my brain cells to calibrate
when you say
give me a sentence for Isara to say
oh
oh dear
bleeding hearts
it's been so long
my voice is cracking but I'm kind of there
you've done me so
well
I'm just waiting
it's not that I'm
hey sweetie
as far as it's impossible
you sound like you're dying
trying to mimic your tone
I've missed you
my bleeding
my voice is a bit too soft
I apologize
you can't just build oni-chan
guard
oh it's like literally my top one
kick
I'm like
it's like that has to be tier one
for me
what would the second
be
the other hole
yeah
try she be
try
she be deeper than me I think
I can't do she be
have you been a good boy
that's not how she be
since
it's cause she's a deeper tone
I'm so sorry
wait I don't know
what did she be saying
oh heron
I can't do it
she be from wish you will fuck you
you need to call us trash
you are trash
nothing but trash
mercy
mercy is higher pitched than me
senpai I've missed you so much
senpai
my voice is cracking on that giggle
oh that's pretty bad if I'm cracking on a giggle
senpai
did you miss me
I'm not even gonna pretend that I can
do anything to me
try her yandere laugh
wait a lorma volume
I'll see if I can do it in the same laugh like
mercy
there we go
igor
thank you for the
wait a minute
igor aren't you from my puzzle stream
remember when imi confessed
that she herself before the stream
that was just strong
thank you for the 5 igor
I'm pretty sure you're from
the puzzle game because
I see rated into me
and then everyone started saying igor
and I was like what the heck is igor
and then everyone started saying the puzzle game
and I was like oh yeah that's the puzzle game
yes I watched it
this one says you're scaring me
I told you I'm all a vealer
you don't trust me
you didn't believe me
just because I've got a scottish accent
doesn't mean I can't even mimic your waifu
it's okay
you're allowed to be scared odd ey
did you hear that
whistle as I breathe in there
love you
your voice actually kind of works
of course my voice
works
everything I do
everything I touch
succeeds
don't you understand
I control all of this
if I want to live
I live
if I want to take
I take
and if I want you to die
you die
that was an assassin's
great brotherhood quote by the way
please do not back
hydration check
I feel like you could tell
whether it's strawny or someone else's voice
shwing
strawny you just can't have your way
right hydration check okay
I have my finger
and all the pies
and my tentacles
and everywhere
hey
can you please
touch the side even
there's only so much
a lower call if I should do
okay I'll go back to whispering
cause my voice doesn't crack when I whisper
for some reason
but if I try and do self spoken ASMR
it's just like completely messed up
much love to you
oh yeah
was that a swing from Wayne's world
yeah I've never seen that
I've just seen meme complete
like the highlights
and the old swing
good memories from assassin's
great oh yeah
was that we're playing assassin's great brotherhood
on the dance of chun can't wait to see you there
oh yeah definitely emotion
that was nothing else
yeah
congrats on the interview
oh but went well
thank you grandpa
thank you again
and to share the wealth
share the load
if you didn't know
there's a quote in lord of the rings
we're sang us to photo share
the load
you'd share your load with me right
reflin
thank you again
I appreciate it
and I go for the super chat
I don't think I said that
he said
sorry my tummy's rumbling
I haven't eaten anything
you said insurance agent
okay
I wonder what that's like
are you gonna be on the phone I wonder
but yeah you don't actually have to share your wealth
make sure your bills are paid
and then any debts
and then if you are in the position
to tip or deny
please consider a dollar first
if you can only do one
always pick a dollar over me
I produce free content all the time
you just have to let me cook
yeah
you're making me
make noises
go down
how do you think the girls were made
share the load then photos
face me
you
Stroni that was too powerful
like I like catching you off-card
one minute
you think I'm about to narrow down
about Lord of the Rings
next minute
your tentacle
is up
nice try
but I need my energy today
okay let me refresh my load
ah there's marshmallows
thank you
first I love you
I love your red light
secondly I have two movies
that I would give my life not for you at watch
please keep it and remember to eat
anything with tomatoes in it
more tomato the better for your boss
Napoleon Dynamite
I've never seen that
this is one of my favourite movies
it's a unique indie movie that is weird
in the best way possible
the other one would be Taladik
Taladik a Knight
what
and it's a comedy that's really goofy and fun
yeah I'm 100% open to
movie suggestions
I'm going to see
if I can push three membership streams
one by default
is a watch along
one by default is
ASMR membership
and then a third one
is either a short video game
a game we might have already played
before
or maybe a multiplayer stream
kind of experience
but yeah please don't be afraid
to suggest things you want to see
I am very open to any
suggestions of content
I don't mind at all
some feed troopers might not like it
I do not mind it please
I'd love to deliver what you seek
thank you for your nice message
Princess Breed
how open to your
our movies
I'm 100% open to our movies
I'll even wear my heart rate monitor
if you like
I don't mind at all
sounds like you're going to love cyberpunk
27.7
you're just like Johnny Silverhand
Johnny Silverhand
or if he wants to burn down society
okay I'm going to enjoy cyberpunk
I wish I got this super
and then I got
censored
kind of smart autism
but I'm stuck with a pro wrestling
fan autism
it's okay brother
much old man Randy Savage
I used to watch
visit the stinger
or the wasp
as a child so don't worry
if you like pro wrestling
I know some names
society
yeah yeah
sorry
yeah
society
anonymous
oh
why
why 100
with no message
I know
I know what the fuck
thank you
why so much money
thank you for the 100
what the fuck I know
and no
do not donate
to put a message that says nothing
so Brian reads out nothing
I know exactly what you're doing
I can see you
smiling to yourself
being all proud
that you tipped without a message
I see you
don't think I don't
I'm staring into your soul don't do it
bad animal
bad boy
you're bad
bad man
animal
do you know what happens to bad men
they need punishment
that's the AC
bring your boot in
how is it my turn again
yay boot time
anon
anon when did I say
what did I fucking say anon
I called it
I called it you were already
freaking typing it in the box
thank you for the tip anonymous
nothing
I'm ginger
what so who
I'm ginger too
or no someone said a little like war millon
and I was like honestly I don't care no little war millon
you call me there
tips
refuses to call me
leaves literally
I don't join them
I'm getting second feelings of scolding
should I do scolding
ASMR
I'm actual fucking agent
what the fuck
I can't do your room and don't make a noise for the rest of the night
I actually can't believe that embarrassment
you've caused me death on the playground today
what me doing
do you know what I'm saying
we've got a scene in school and it says lacy basher
you're not supposed to be a lacy basher
I didn't really I didn't
sorry I can't do that any faster
I didn't raise a lacy basher
to screw
don't tell me what I can tell
this is actually true in
Scotland
on the playground
you're told not to hit girls
and the way you're told not to hit girls
is you get called
a lacy basher
this is true
any scouts lurking
know what a lacy basher is
you'll basically get called a lacy basher
in bullied and picked on
for hitting girls you do know
hit girls in Scotland
and then
until you look at the domestic violence rates
yeah
lacy bashing doesn't work
which one of you
took a shit
and did they flush that toilet
don't bash my lassies
I got most of that
and enjoyed it
oh that was my collar crack if you're
heard that
how many movies
are we playing in advance
oh wait how many movies are you playing
in advance in this picturesque
nodding and nothing can stop you
oh I
learned long ago
if you ever stream
or make primary content asmr
and then you deviate from that
people
are like raise asmr raise asmr
and then they filter themselves
so I took that knowledge
and applied here little refling
so don't be nervous
if you see my sub numbers going up
it's already been planned
thank you for trusting me
little refling
do you like
18 plus
art if there's a male
involved?
you can make it
a generic
white outline of a guy
like a protagonist
like self insert protagonist
in order
excuse me
stomach in order
to make it
a refling
you just need to put a nicotine patch on the head
yeah
oh my stomach is really rumbling
maybe I should put the mic to my stomach
you're literally
yes
just put a nicotine patch
on a white outline of a guy
if you want like a guy
standard type thing going on
that's how you draw everything
yeah
a scrawny was wondering
if you try a new monster hunter
there's a new monster hunter
sorry there's a new monster hunter
I didn't even know that
I want to put
my entire tongue
inside your
the other one
you are cute thank you
I'm glad you like it
oh it comes in next year
okay
do you want to hear my tummy
okay I'll let you hear my tummy why no
I haven't eaten today
okay so I don't know I'm loud
and maybe you may actually hear my heart
do you hear anything
do you hear it
it
you're just above
my belly button
are you a little bit hungry
yeah I haven't had anything to eat
yeah I don't really eat before stream
but yeah when I make
the
pregnant with you ASMR
it's gonna have my actual tummy
sounds in it like you really are in the womb
I'll eat after stream
in 20 minutes
wait that's my tummy
your stomach sounds are my new favorite trigger
oh if you don't stomach sound ASMR
I'll make that that's so easy to make
literally 15 minutes of silence
I just like a microphone to my stomach
you can 100% have that
maybe I can name it something like
laying on girlfriend's stomach ASMR
but it won't stop f-ing rumbling
like to make it a meme title
when you want that
pregnancy ASMR
we can't just say that
yeah I would love that
okay
consider it on my today list then
cause that's like super easy to make
ASMR wise
literally put the microphone
on my stomach
and be silent for 15 minutes
and then apply a noise gate filter
and then that's it we're done
giant ASMR when
um
I do have one
Azura has one
I'm gonna make Emmy do one
cause I want her book to go terribly wrong
I'll make a plot where she's tired
being the smallest that be a lure
and then ends up becoming a giant
for like 24 hours
when would that be uploaded
I want to say soon dm
maybe within the month
I'll try my best
Stoney goes crack and mood
laying on girlfriend's stomach while she's waiting
for her door dash order
that's actually really good I might steal that
I'm not being funny I might actually
just straight up steal your idea
thank you for that yonk me now
no way I love you for that Stoney you're the best
what do you mean
wait for the giant ASMR the stomach
honestly
I
I am always like super happy
to make you guys happy
and I always want your ideas
to be our ideas
communism
that door dasher
me literally
she has oh sorry
she has the spell to make her thingies bigger
but instead turns herself into a giant ass
I know like I
okay this is a little
a little fun fact
about me I actually
really enjoy giant this
giant ism
which is why
Azura can become
a giant
but she can only be as tall as a skyscraper
she can be indefinitely
big
but she is a god at the end of the day
but because she gave up some of her divinity
and she has like a regular human
height of 185 cm
I wasn't kidding when I said the girls
were based after my kings
I don't care what anyone says is true
but yes I tiny shrunken
ja I wanted to do
swallowing ASMR
as well where I
get so hungry little reefling
and you look like calamari
and I swallow you
and you're in my tummy and I'm like talking to you
whilst you're getting
digested by me
yeah I just like these kind of
things I'm sorry
no please don't
eat us
I just like these things
I think I'm so creative
I really do
well I'm proud to be here
dinner
help I'm scared
only eat us
in this other god time
wait I'm on the fence about being
eaten we'll see what you think
after the audio comes out
maybe you'll like it maybe you won't
as always
don't subject your
tentacle to something
you know you don't like
when is your ink
rating stream
probably next week
it will be my membership stream
where we rate
everything
and I get to be as unhinged
as I desire I'm going to be
speaking about all the
scenarios I want to
be doing on ya
I'm not holding back
I mean being
eaten by you was on the table since
debut I assure you
I'm very nutritious
wow my stomach really
is making noises now
always giving a try to audio
so you don't know if you like it or not
yeah some people that didn't think
they were going to enjoy the patreon
tell me are you okay
some people thought
they didn't
they weren't going to enjoy
my alternative audio
of a unique variation
and they really enjoyed it
which I'm glad it was like a fun
challenge
I enjoyed it very much
there's literally
no word that can come out of your mouth
I don't love hearing and inking for
go get food
I'm redirecting
very shortly I'll get food then
I like being with you
I don't want to get distracted
go get food
if you're going to eat me
at least give me a good time
maybe I'll pretend
that you're getting digested
but I'll just foam it you up again
the bully patreon
what from Emmy
of being with your dad
thank ya
or do you mean the party one
where the pew
picks on you at a party
I think she'd be had some problems
today
why
problems with what
I'm turned for
trying most times
except for
dig
because it just makes me sound
oh I'm sorry to hear that
out of the audios
out there audios are so fun
there's one ASMR that makes a bunch of audios
with listener
perishes
is that macabre? I know exactly
how you're talking about macabre
oh no I think they changed their name
I can't remember what their new name is
your voice gets me distracted
good
it shit
chubby weekend tags
are my favourite
I have terrible news patreon banner
I can't even
I could probably do something on twitter with that
but patreon banner
instead of
one you could just
okay yeah I can bill ya
once you've had your time
in the tummy tummy time
the demo one was so good
it was my first
ever freaking audio
and I was like so nervous
to do it
it was like
oh yes do you like that
oh I bet you do
but come to bed with me
like it was
so nerve wracking
I was like no one is going to enjoy this
I'm so glad you enjoy it
I don't know
if I like the voice or the attitude
I like to hear everything makes it
I'm a spider
I thought
there's a cat here in my mouth
there's a freaking cat here
Kimly
Kimly your freaking cat here
went in my mouth
oh your patreon content is good
thank ya
I can't remember what the next
blog being uploaded is
um
yeah patreon literally
said feedurism ban
well no master card
just said it's ban because it's like
dangerous or whatever
that cat here literally me
you're in my
do you hypnotize yourself
no I can
but
lore wise
mirrors are my biggest weakness
and when I do my tonathon
you guys are going to be sick
of those blogs
I freaking love
don't lose so much
I don't care what anyone says
it's so good
like please
parade me around like a pup
credit card companies need to stop
yes
it's crazy
how much
I mean they literally run the world
whilst they are banning all this stuff
and they're all jumping on ebstein island
like you literally can't make this stuff up
they ban feedurism
but they're all chilling on ebstein island
bruv
get a fucking grip
honestly this is so annoying
don't look in the right but hold you'll go too deep
well time to get a mirror
are you afraid of mirrors
it's because
if I look into a mirror
like this I can hypnotize myself
cause I fall for the spiral
okay
so I can't look at mirrors
while I'm trying to hypnotize you
or else I'm in trouble
don't lose as long as it's huge
morning good morning
I want astrony conspiracy
theory stream
you asked I will deliver
oh my god
like I know I keep mentioning needy streamer overload
I was so surprised
that they had that kind of
thing because I was like wait a minute
I'm interested in this stuff
but I am aware
it may filter a lot of people
but
then again
more intimate streams
I just might
briefly
I just may
I'm just glad
everyone is pleased yeah
we're probably like we don't really judge around here
just have a good time
all at just
astrony conspiracy theory stream
oh that's gonna take me
hours to prepare my presentation
I'm gonna come with a breath
I'm gonna come with a receipt
I'm gonna change your perspective
on everything
they can't handle listening to the truth
I'm gonna put a tinfoil hat on myself
and I will offer you all
to wear a tinfoil hat on stream too
feeler is going
for cultural victory
exactly
oh should you be streaming
this stream is a perfect test for my new headphones
oh yeah can you hear me in this ear
what if I go into
this ear does it sound like
I am going ear to ear
it's kind of amazing technology
isn't it
I'll let you guess like me
oh please let me make you break you please
please for me
I'll be a good little girl
if you let me make
break you
I had to dream the other night
I had to dream I had you in a standing position
but I was lifting you
your little legs were swaying
as I was moving
a lot of painting and roughness
and fall of brief light
oh my god
query on head
song sure a good girl
damn right I'm a good girl
let me make your headphones
ok yeah I'm convinced
wow
did our legs swayed
to improve
to diamond
an audio where you try and hypnotize
she be but end up seeing a mirror
and hypnotizing yourself
and she takes advantage
of the situation would be quite interesting
interesting
is that
a donut on public
reward
I think it is
wait for us
ok
I will be working one on one
with the sura to help our donut on
rewards and
if it goes well I think
I think a sura can move out
and I'm so excited for her
anyway
know that you are so close
I must say
I like a lot of little green
parts of my hair yeah
I have a few strands of green
out but that's just because
I can't keep it all away I have such
big hair
could you please put the headlights
on share
but it won't be
hi refly
it's me again
just talking to your subconscious
don't worry
I won't do anything
not this day
but this is just a reminder
I own you
all of you
your thoughts
your mind
just a reminder
my hair
did I turn off the reverb
is the reverb off
did I turn it off
or did I not hit the button
yes it's off
did you do it on me
sounds off okay get the reverb
wasn't on oh it never came on
it was supposed to come on
I guess I never hit the button hard enough
reverb would never turn on
okay damn it don't need to again
this is a reminder wait is it broken
oh I think it might be broken
oops I broke it
oopsies I broke it
oops it seems like I dropped my mirror
face up I hope you don't like that
yes you won't be I was never on
do it again it's broken
I don't know why it's not working
when you mentioned about AC using her boots
to step on us and nearly triggered
something in me also
you trying to hypnotize us on a ship
the ships
the ship's hair gets into your mouth
causing you to look down and get hypnotized
by your reflection
that's so good
wait what almost triggered you
my jisun
you almost got triggered
are you really that badly
minded
that's something so sweet
and innocent
and pharaoh like me
could hurt you
jisun
and you'd like it
you're so dirty
I can't feel sorry AC
I'm so sorry AC
we're all plain as magic in me
is that a thing that's weird I don't know if I'm crossing a boundary
I should probably ask them
I don't know
it's not the oos in chat
over me
surprise this is my actual voice
you're going ooo to AC's mimic
if my voice wasn't
broken
I wonder if I could smoothly do AC's voice
I can hardly do it
without causing the crack in my voice
that's very hard
cause she's higher pitched than me
we'll get them next time
um
that could be a fun idea
everyone has that person
well I begs the AC
cause she's so cute
I'm so sorry AC
I can impersonate
well I begs the AC cause she's the only one I can impersonate
with male
with male success
I wonder if it's cause she's European
that I can mimic
that seems silly but at the same time
she is the only voice
your voices are your favourite
we're very Sean Connery
when it's deep
ah yes
I can make my acting even stronger
but I don't talk on stream like this
cause
hardly anyone can understand
what the heck I'm saying
so
do you mean
do
sorry do you mean just having a big white square
over the male's face with the nicotine patch
on the head maybe I understand
or I'm just stupid
oh no you're not stupid you silly goober
sorry for that idea
I had a character we need eyes and a mouth
um
if you go on my alternative twitter
that art
why am I
I was not asleep
papaparito
drew a wiggling head on a man
if you need a mouth and eyes
you can maybe do that
oh Jesus
I'm in danger gonna get double teamed up
by double AC
it's normal for Scottish
using so many hours then
so
you guys say girl
but we say ghetto
like oh you're a ghetto
like good ghetto
your last ASMR stream
when you kissed on the head I felt it
Larry
thank you for feeling that
I say
when your collab for double eastern european
would go hard
honestly yeah
I'm done for the slavic
hey thank you so much for the tip
I appreciate it
and I'm glad you could feel it in your tip
hey yeah
hi day strongy
I just wanted to share how much I've been loving
you and your content and the grilles
I wish I could share more
love with your doors
but feel her mom
has got it going on
all of her doors have been streamed
and so long
reeflings can you see
I might not be the oshi for you
wait
can you see there's an oshi
what the f... I can't pick a song
you're literally too perfect
in the fact that I can make you happy
by making your doors happy as even bear
yeah
I was curious about your preferences
and pep use
I had to thought about a video
but then I wasn't sure if the visuals
marriage is much as sound I would make
so I was wondering oh audio's work
yes they work audio works
very well yes please
anyway I look forward to all your content
thank you
and everything else you do in my heart
thanks very much
I want to love you and help the girl succeed
I appreciate that I love you too
thank you for such kind message
sorry if I sent twice
tomorrow is tricky it is tricky
she be reminder
oh I'm actually calling
in a favor for a friend
we're gonna redirect
actually Mollie should make me live right now
we're calling in a favor
for a friend okay an old friend
we are going to redirect
into mimosa
because mimosa
is letting me steal her voice
for an asmr collab
I believe she is live
with asmr right now she is
okay we're calling in a friend
we're calling in a friend
a favor for a friend
mimosa is agreed to do an asmr collab
with me she's gonna redirect
back into another vlr girl
so please don't worry please enjoy mimosa
this is called
team building
team exercising
she's been very open to me
even though I'm dirty dirty
and she's been very kind to consider it
so
please do
why doesn't Mollie
redirect into her
mimosa
accuse me please
yes sorry for such a short asmr stream
sadly my voice breaks too easily
why
the frick
can I not host into it
mimosa
mimosa you're giving me a
okay I've got it I've got it I've got it save
I've got it
thank you so so much mimosa is redirecting
into a vlr girl after this
I'm actually working on
her first asmr collab with a feature
for audio like literally
the stream ends I'm so freaking excited
so thank you so so much
reeflings I am so appreciative
of your
you have been
nothing but a little
miracle entering my life again
or maybe entering it for the first time
special thank you to all the
super chats to all the memberships
and the donations that was some very
big donations
and I cannot wait
to see to show you what week
three hasn't stole from memberships
but again please don't worry
if you can't remember
I always have free streams and content
stream sniping and everything
so please
have a fantastic evening for the rest
of it and say hi to mimosa
for me I'm going to speak in her chat
for a little bit okay so I'll see
you in mimosa's chat
bye reeflings love you
make sure you hydrate and eat
I'm gonna eat and talk to mimosa
okay bye bye reeflings
thank you
oh my tummy
my tummy keeps rumbling